[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos de
nuevo en esta ocasión iniciamos con un
logro médico y tecnológico tres personas
que habían quedado parapléjicas tras
sufrir accidentes en moto lograron
ponerse de pie caminar pedalear en
bicicleta e incluso nadar pero como se
logró esta hazaña
neurocientíficos de la ciudad suiza de
lausana realizaron una intervención
quirúrgica de cuatro horas en la que
implantaron 16 electrodos directamente
en la médula espinal de los pacientes
estos electrodos envían señales desde
los laterales de la columna lo que
permite focalizar las y activar regiones
muy específicas de la médula espinal a
su vez los electrodos van conectados a
un sistema de inteligencia artificial
que emite señales para estimular nervios
individuales que controlan el movimiento
muscular en el tronco y en las piernas
simulando las órdenes que daría el
cerebro para caminar levantarse o
sentarse
en una persona sana hoy un mensaje
activa del cerebro a través de la médula
espinal porque activa el conjunto de
motoneuronas que a su vez acción ciertos
músculos es algo que ni siquiera
pensamos llega automáticamente y podemos
hablar o hacer otras cosas mientras
caminamos
wild walking
indistinguibles en este estudio usamos
tecnología específicamente diseñada lo
que significa que cada electrodo está
posicionado con precisión para activar
toda la región que envuelve el control
de movimiento del tronco y las piernas
ley bosman recordemos que estas personas
habían perdido todo el movimiento y las
sensaciones de las extremidades
inferiores debido al corte completo de
la médula y como lo decían los expertos
una de las claves de este estudio es que
por primera vez los electrodos y los
cables que llevan conectados fueron
fabricados específicamente teniendo en
cuenta las lesiones particulares de cada
participante
anteriormente se usaban electrodos
diseñados para tratar el dolor una hora
después de la cirugía los pacientes ya
podían dar sus primeros pasos con la
ayuda de un arnés pasado el tiempo
lograron montar en bicicleta
a nadar al aire libre este entrenamiento
se debe también a que sus músculos se
encontraban atrofiados por la falta de
uso de beijing it's not al principio no
era muy fácil porque necesitaban
soportar su peso y entender lo que
estaba pasando pero pudieron usar sus
piernas de inmediato y dar paso a
beckham active inyecte de álex and under
and the modern trade cuanto más
entrenaban comenzaron a desarrollar los
músculos y el movimiento se volvió más
sabia con esta tecnología caminaré
florería to work with this technology
it's in the movement jessie nidia el
movimiento es inmediato pero debes
entender cómo se hace y se vuelve cada
vez mejor el cuerpo se va no soy traidor
show que the news tweets es clave de
entender que los electrodos están
conectados a un sistema de inteligencia
artificial es decir pueden ser
controlados mediante un dispositivo como
un celular o una tableta es desde esa
herramienta que se programa la señal u
orden que se requiere para realizar
determinada actividad
el software se adapta a la anatomía de
cada paciente los científicos crearon
una compañía de tecnología llamada
américo establecida en países bajos y
con el sistema que desarrollaron esperan
que en 2023 se puede hacer un ensayo
clínico con entre 70 y 100 pacientes
principalmente en eeuu
nextel el próximo paso es aplicar la
misma precisión en el desarrollo de una
plataforma de neuroestimulación entonces
el sistema implantable que está en el
abdomen y genera la estimulación
necesitamos que sea más preciso más
conectado lo que significa que con un
reloj inteligente o un teléfono se pueda
controlar así el paciente podrá utilizar
muy fácilmente esta tecnología en la
vida real y al like vamos ahora hasta
taiwán sabemos que el uso de tapabocas
tan necesario durante la pandemia ha
generado toneladas de desechos que están
contaminando el medio ambiente pues la
firma miniwiz está recogiendo las
mascarillas ya usadas que fueron
fabricadas con polímeros del plástico
para desarrollar partes de un cargador
para celular
especialmente las mascarillas están
hechas casi en un 100% de plástico es
base de polipropileno y pensamos que tal
si pudiéramos transformar toda esta
polución en lugar de votarla y dejarla
allá afuera cómo podemos transformarla
en un producto que funcione fue entonces
cuando se nos ocurrió esta nueva
generación de cargadores digitales
inalámbricos la empresa desarrolló una
máquina llamada trash preso que combina
una trituradora un compresor y un brazo
mecánico para producir automáticamente
parte de los cargadores
el aparato tritura las mascarillas las
calienta y las convierte en una especie
de masa plástica es así como se fabrica
la carcasa de estos cargadores el banco
taiwanesa football financial colaboro
con mini wheats para ofrecer el producto
a sus empleados
en principio recolectamos alrededor de
10 mil mascarillas les agregamos
materiales proporcionados permiten whist
e hicimos más de 40.000 cargadores para
nuestros empleados estamos muy felices
de recibir este regalo porque los
aparatos serán diferentes estaban hechos
con mascarillas recicladas y finalizamos
con un tema para los amantes de la
cerveza estudiantes de la universidad de
adelaida en australia crearon la primera
cerveza desarrollada mediante
inteligencia artificial del estilo
indian fail y para según expertos
cazadores que la han probado se trata de
un producto de alta calidad
básicamente hicimos la receta de receta
recolectamos datos creamos redes para
procesarlos y logramos una cerveza de la
inteligencia artificial en la visión de
jean spears así llegamos al final de
este espacio los invitamos a continuar
con nosotros en france24 voy a visitar y
ampliar todos los contenidos en france
24 punto com